the Oscars were up 18 in viewership and
my contribution was but nobody watched
the ads the value proposition of a
commercial on television is zero if the
ads happen to be decent somewhat
interesting it could still be a much
more viable medium than it is today it's
why the Super Bowl in America continues
to work I would argue a lot of the ads
are not good but it's a cultural
phenomenon to tune in and by the way
most tick tocks are not valuable either
it's just there's so many of them on a
daily basis that even if one percent is
good that's a lot of good whereas
television commercials are low none of
them are good more than half of them are
a complete waste of 20 million dollars I
think it's just a cultural phenomenon
for us to all be joined in